across the broad expanse of history
there have been billions upon billions
of idiots as well as a handful of smart
people we interviewed some of the latter
group for our ongoing series great minds
people who think good this week's people
who thinks good Jane Goodall achieved
her childhood dream to live with and
study the chimpanzees in Africa to whom
she gave exotic names at this point she
had no formal training or even an
undergraduate degree but the discoveries
of this daring young woman
revolutionized our understanding of
these primates starting with this
bombshell the chimpanzee is actually
modifying a natural object to suit it to
a specific purpose thus making her -
that's right
chips were making and using tools albeit
pretty crappy tools for a pretty
disgusting purpose but she also found
something else chimpanzees like humans
have a dark side to their nature
yes Goodall was also the first to show
that these peaceful forest vegetarians
were actually meat-eating who
frequently engaged in chimp eat chimp on
chimp chimp aside after decades in the
field Goodall now spends her time
traveling the world to fight for a
variety of causes with occasional
interruptions to speak with a not so
smart person dr. Jane Goodall thank you
so much for taking the time to speak
with me well thank you for inviting me
you are widely recognized as one of the
great experts on chimpanzees what makes
them particularly so fascinating to you
I think because they're so like us and
you know we now know biologically we
share 98 plus percent of our DNA with
them blood system the immune system the
structure of the brain is all almost the
same just our brain is bigger and then
for me of course it's the behavior the
fact that they have personalities they
have emotions like happiness sadness
fear they communicate with kissing
embracing holding hands passing one
another on the back shaking the fist
they use tools is that what makes them
such great pets possible they're not
pets
I can't even say they're bad pets cuz
they're not pets well I mean they're
nice acquaintances housebound friends or
not and what happens they're very cute
and sweet and cuddly when they're little
and what happens when they're 5 6 7 and
why do people have their face bitten off
don't focus on that though focus on the
fact that when you dress them up they're
so funny
chimpanzee but no at no point in your
time living amongst chimpanzees did you
think about pulling out a little monocle
and a top hat and a silver tray and
training them to bring you a cold drink
did you ever put a hat on them you never
put a hat on a chimpanzee I refuse to
believe that disagree for the rest of
our lives okay fair enough let's talk a
little about your methods they were not
without their initial criticisms for
instance at one point of contention was
that you gave your chimps nicknames why
did people criticize that yeah well not
nicknames names just names there's no
actual names to be scientific I should
have given them numbers what's the
scientific argument for not giving them
now cause it's more objective so if you
give them a name you're treating them
like people I'm gonna throw some names
at you and I want you to say if you
think there would be a good name for a
chimp or a bad name for a chimp ready
Jessica Simpson doctor been an appeal MD
fair enough how about this is a little
simpler poothrow wilson right yeah
that's fine
okay that's good so you throw somebody
else where are you going they're
throwing people that I think need thrown
at them I mean I'm gonna pick somebody
like Hitler because he's gone right
poothrow hitler great who drove here
there's been an amazing line for a chimp
now what you were living with them you
learned that chimps had specific
vocalizations so can you tell me a
little about that well if I'm eating
something like you know and you want
some you come up to me right
you might big just like that yeah but I
don't want to give you an easily of this
you say dr. Jane Goodall thank you so
much
[Applause]
[Laughter]